hollande au michigan
ici même en hiver pas besoin de bottes
si vous marchez au centre-ville 8 km de
trottoirs ils sont chauffés la ville a
même commencé à étendre l'expérience au
résidentiel
la population semble apprécié je marche
une heure par jour sans avoir peur de
glisser cette résidente les clients les
souliers sec sa garde mon magasin plus
propres ajoute cette commerçante
certaine que les trottoirs attire des
clients d'ailleurs on installa allemande
le même genre de système qu'il y aurait
pu avoir rue sainte catherine
ces petits tuyaux rouge sous le pavé
maintiennent la température à 5 degrés
celsius sur les trottoirs c'est une
technologie prouvée
c'est une bonne idée dans son concept
tout dépend d'où provient l'énergie qui
est utilisée pour faire fondre la neige
montréal pensé utiliser l'électricité
pour chauffer les trottoirs de la rue
sainte-catherine comme le fait oslo en
norvège pour son centre ville où vient
sapporo au japon pour plusieurs de ses
trottoirs mais ça aurait été du
gaspillage d'énergie assez coûteux pense
daniel rousse ils vendent plutôt à
l'inde où c'est l'eau réchauffée par la
centrale électrique local qui chauffent
les trottoirs ce qui ne coûte rien en
énergie ou reykjavik en islande où de
nombreux trottoirs sont chauffés à la
vapeur
normal à reykjavik la vapeur sortent du
sol en islande la grandeur du territoire
alors ça serait bête de s'en passer et
il n'y a pas grand chose d'autre qu'on
peut faire avec de la vapeur avec la
chaleur ici l'idée de vendre de
l'électricité encore une fois ce thème
c'était moins 7 1 - gagnant spécialiste
en design urbain françois racine lui est
déchue du choix de la nouvelle
administration
finie la glace fini les désagréments
fini aussi toute la machinerie qui
viennent
abîmer le mobilier urbain fini les
abrasifs je croyais qu au niveau design
au beurre balistique cette équipe était
plus sensible à ces questions le projet
de trois shows enfin emballer aurait
transformé l'expérience au centre ville
s'inspire en europe
chaput estomac qui confondent le dire
car on n'est pas capable de réaliser
falloir que dans une telle européenne on
y aille mais installé ses trottoirs
chauffants auraient coûté trop cher
pense l'institut de développement urbain
la priorité est un bon revêtement une
expérience agréable
la rapidité des traboules le respect des
échéanciers dans ce contexte-là 30
millions pour 550 m de rue on n'était
certainement pas convaincu que c'était
la bonne chose à faire
projet montréal souhaite donner un effet
whaou à la nouvelle rue sainte catherine
on sera en mars ce qui remplacera les
trottoirs chauffant ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio-canada m'ont rien